health clinic.
>> 2 1/2 E weeks it's now
opening.
Can I ask you about this movie,
you were in an extra in a movie
called "White noise".
Let's watch a clip of it.
>> Let's watch a sitcom or
something.
>> No.
>> They're calling it the
airborne toxic event.
>> The plot is a train crash in
Ohio leaves to the release of
deadly toxins, the main
character and his family have to
evacuate, how long after the
crash on the third did you think
of "White noise"?
You were an extra in movie.
>> Probably the 4th.
More than a fire and train
derailment, the chemicals.
After the movie came out I
watched it and really the first
third is about the train
incident and the last 75% of the
movie is kind of its own story
that doesn't have to do we vac
wags but really early on it's
very surprisingly the exact
same, I think it kind of goes to
show that kind of the human
condition.
We're always fighting against
the powers.
Trying to juggle the idea of how
serious this situation is and
what level do I need to kind of
react to it and you can kind of
feel that from the film.
>> I don't know I would have
watched it on the 4th after the
crash in my town in Ohio.
>> No.
I tried but couldn't.
>> You gave it some time.
>> Yeah, yeah.